foreign
[Music]
thank you
demolition of any homes or properties of
the protected population that's a
Palestinian population in the occupied
Palestinian territories is against
International humanitarian law and could
amount to war crimes there's an
exception for absolute military
necessity but the vast majority in fact
all the cases that we have documented
are not military Necessities they are
illegal demolitions of homes and they
might amount to forcible displacement
which is also War crime
[Music]
thank you
there's a wider systematic problem in
the occupied Palestinian territories and
indeed in Israel that civilians or
Palestinians are systematically
discriminated against their children
growing up in these conditions will feel
feel hopeless they will feel that there
is no justice they will feel isolated
and Abandoned and this is where there
are there's a role to the International
Community where everybody has a duty not
to be maintaining apartheid and not to
be supporting war crimes such as illegal
settlement project
[Music]